foreign
bought five horses using credit cards
without my knowledge while I was out of
the country oh we've reconciled after
that Rocky stage in our marriage and we
decided to sell the horses she sold
three of the horses but now one of the
two remaining horses is sick she argues
that we need to restore the horse's
health so that we are able to sell it
she bought the horse for five thousand
dollars and hopes to sell it for two
thousand dollars if it's healthy I would
like to euthanize the horse but my wife
doesn't have a problem going into more
debt to save it how do we Define a limit
on expenses for the horse's recovery
after which if he doesn't get well we
can just decide for euthanasia oh my
goodness George are you sweating I have
assorted past with horse related
questions on the show Christina if you
all know I I took a call a long while
ago with Rachel and I told the girl to
sell the horse that call is like
legendary now yeah and so to get this is
not a trolling like someone actually
sent this question and this is not
trolling from the booth guys
um and it
listen I will say this horse people
there's two kinds they're either very
well wealthy or they're broke and this
is like an addiction level yeah you know
what I mean if this was good probably
would say you have a problem
so they're trying to get out of this
mess obviously I am not a part of the
equestrian Community I did look up
obviously options for this and here's my
take I don't think they should sink
money into this thing and I don't think
they should euthanize the horse I think
there's another option let's hear it
George because there's what they're
saying is hey should we sink another
five grand into the horse to get it back
on its hooves
all to then sell it for two so either
way they're losing a ton of money on
this my option would be why don't we try
to market the horse privately or look
into horse rescues that would be willing
to take this horse on and help it
recover the that's good doesn't look
like a better option yes that's good
that's good that's a that's a good in
between spot where it's like no more
depth and obviously we can all agree
euthanasia is a worst worst latch lash
ditch option right not the option we
want to go with if we can get the horse
on his feet without sinking too much
money well George you actually love
animals I feel like you got a lot of
hate from horse gate but you actually
have quite a strong relationship and
don't want the horse to to die
absolutely so yes if you are if you're a
gun hoe about trying to help this horse
recover I would set a limit and say
listen let's get a let's get an estimate
from the vet and if we're willing to do
that and we're willing to cash flow it
meaning we're not going to go more
further into debt for this then I would
look into the recovery but if you're
gonna have to go into more debt we're
getting rid of the horse and giving it
to someone who can financially take care
of it that's good I feel like that's a
win-win that's a win-win on that and
then I would also recommend you all go
through FPU again Financial Peace
University because it sounds like you
all worked through some of the marriage
issues you know you sold horses and all
of that but that that desire to still go
into debt is still there with your wife
she hasn't had that I've had it moment
the fact that she's you know kind of
immediately going to oh well let's just
you know spend money on a credit card to
help heal the horse like that's just
that's not a strong foundation so I
would work through that maybe even
consider going through some Financial
coaching
um because yeah there's been there's
been a lot that's happened in your
marriage that trust that was breached is
the most pressing matter in this whole
situation that's hard to repair well and
it's hard to see once again you know
you've been through so much with the
fact that she went into debt for the
horses to begin with and now she's
immediately going hey here's an issue
let's go into debt again like that's got
to kind of spark something on the inside
yeah but George of course problems I
think that everybody needs a little bit
of an update on horses oh my goodness do
I have an update for you so we just did
a a Building Wealth event in
Indianapolis and Katie who is the person
that called in with the horse call who I
told to sell her horse and I said worse
things was at the event she drove five
hours to be at the event and we're we're
cool we've missed message on Instagram I
love getting updates from her she was
awesome
and our social team was there and they
made a little clip and so if you're
listening on radio it'll be hard to
follow I'm going to recap it after we're
done but let's check out that update on
horse gate you know your whole story
the Zelda horse could you sell the horse
I can't why not I've had this horse 11
years
Katie Katie there's other horses out
there it doesn't even know your name for
horses for you on the other side sure
listen I want Katie to win yeah she's
here
George
he even looks like me he has my email
here from high school and tell me the
dog doesn't even know my name yes George
the dog doesn't even know your name it
hurts as much as I thought it was her
oh thank you
wow what an interaction she stuck around
when she came to the meet and greet I
signed her book she gave me a picture of
a new horse she got named goose and she
nicknamed it George and this comes up
with her friend group as it does with
mine a week has not gone by with without
mentioning this situation and I signed
her book and I said the horse does know
your name and so he had a beautiful full
circle moment and I got an update from
her on where she's at with her debt-free
journey
so when she called in she was about 120
000 in debt making about 36 000 working
for the USDA full-time and couldn't find
a side hustle in her rural community the
horse was bringing in 300 bucks a month
it was injured she lost that side hustle
and so since then she has paid 12 393
dollars and she has a goal to pay off
the remaining 113k in the next two years
because she got a new side hustle
painting interior houses oh so she's
already made like five grand doing house
painting and she enjoys it it makes
great money and so there was a happy
ending to this story that's great and I
think that's important to note because
you got a lot of hate for that well
here's where I went wrong and I
immediately regretted this after it came
out of my mouth when I said the horse
doesn't know your name because I know
horses are have like deep connection
soul level connections with their owners
and it's a beautiful thing and no the
people like would you sell your dog and
I was like no my dog doesn't need a farm
now my dog was thousands of dollars
because they're luxury designer dogs
that's just what we like but no I would
not sell my dog I mean would you be sad
if somebody said they didn't know your
name my dog for sure doesn't know my
name my dogs are not the brightest
horses are way smarter I feel like
that's a healthy relationship with your
animal it is but I I do stand by the
fact that I mean she emailed into the
show and she was like this is a
prize-winning horse it's worth twenty
thousand dollars I was like oh no Katie
you're only making my point to sell a
horse and as we see it's not an ethic
medical moral if you sell a horse that's
fine if you're not a bad person if you
sell a horse but me telling someone to
sell the horse was apparently where the
line is that's probably the way you said
it the way I said it but here's why I
cared more about Katie's future than I
did her present day horse that was the
truth I wanted to see Katie win and
looking at the numbers on paper it hurt
my heart because I'm going oh my gosh
there's there's no way out of this thing
it's going to take a decade or more to
get out of debt which is not okay and
she's young she's vibrant she has a
whole life ahead of her and that is why
I gave her that advice she did not take
it she sold she did sell one of her
horses that was kind of retired and
bought this one this newer one oh so of
course people let me tell you they are
they are intense they are die hard and
they're willing to spare no expense for
their beloved horses man so well and
it's just it's nice to see a full circle
moment and to see her acknowledge like
hey you know that was good advice but I
think that visceral reaction is is
pretty common whenever you're trying to
get out of debt and there's a lot of
things you might be willing to sell
there's a lot of things that you're
willing to part with but there are
certain things especially with guys and
trucks
yeah and you heard her at the end she
said you lit a fire under my butt and
whenever I'm making a decision my
friends go what would George say and so
I like that I got into her head in that
way just going what could you do get
creative what are you willing to
sacrifice so that the next 20 years of
your life don't suffer in mediocrity
that you can actually get to where you
want to go and not have anything hold
you back so that was the heart of it
Katie you're awesome if you're watching
out there we are cheering you on the
step-free journey and I can't wait for
your debt free scream please bring the
horse please
love that
we're gonna need a cleanup crew on that
day